Good morning, John. It's Monday, January 29th,
and I'm standing on top of Little Pisgah Mountain,
just like you were. Dad insisted that I use
this plane clip in the video. I don't know
why.
I actually filmed that video three days ago,
but you have no way of knowing that. How's
that for movie magic? So it's three days later
now, and we've done the jaunt to Athens, and
I'm at a friend's house. We've been having
a good time in Athens. It's a pretty nice
city; I suggest you try it on sometime.
Today's video is a short video because last
night, my friends and I spent quite a long
time creating a project that I would like
to share with you, as it is inspired by you!
As an added bonus, you will get to see my
wife, Katherine. Apparently she’s not quite
the yeti that your wife is, and will occasionally
come out in public. Also, you may notice featured
in this video, Brian Nuse and Jesslyn Shields,
two of my best friends, who live here in Athens
and assisted me with this project a very great
deal.
(Singing)
Will you miss me when I’m gone from your
pants?
Will you miss me when I'm gone from your pants?
Will you miss me when I’m gone, gone, gone?
Will you miss me when I’m gone from your
pants?
(guitar and tambourine join in)
Will you miss me when I’m gone from your
pants?
Will you miss me when I’m gone? From your
pants!
Will you miss me when I’m gone, gone, gone?
Will you miss me when I’m gone from your
pants?
(laughter)
That’s all! There you have it. I’ll see
you tomorrow.
You know how some DVDs have bonus features?
Well, Brotherhood 2.0 has bonus features too,
and you’re about to see one. You might expect
that “Will You Miss Me When I'm Gone from
Your Pants?” took more than one take to
film. It did. Here’s the first take.
(singing)
Will you miss me when I’m gone from your
pants?
Will… (Group bursts into laughter)
Katherine: That wasn’t even me!